[Musique]
bonsoir antoine on soit au vol et au
menu ce soir une double infox visant le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
sinon vous allez me dire ça faisait bien
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas eu une info
qui autour de volodymyr zelensky deux
fausses informations plus sérieusement
basé sur des vidéos des tournées comme
souvent avec la même accusation à chaque
fois volodymyr zelensky consomme de la
cocaïne la première c'est cette vidéo
que vous apercevez ici largement relayé
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment sur
les comptes télégramme pro russe elle a
surgi le 23 avril dernier relayé
également sur twitter c'est l'exemple
que j'ai choisi pour vous on y voit donc
une courte vidéo du président ukrainien
visiblement visioconférence avec elon
musk relenza on l'aperçoit en bas de
l'écran et surtout on voit de la poudre
blanche sur son bureau avec une carte
bancaire bien évidemment de la cocaïne
bien sûr cet utilisateur lui vous
l'apercevez ils y voient une bourde du
cameraman évidemment c'est un montage
assez habile il faut tout de même
l'avouer la vidéo originale elle a été
repérée très rapidement par les
internautes elle existe ici sur youtube
je voulais y joue c'est une très courte
vidéo on voit bien évidemment qu'il n'y
a pas de drogue sur le bureau de
volodymyr zelensky naturellement ont
d'ailleurs au d'ailleurs on pouvait en
s'attardant un peu sur la vidéo soit dié
présumée de cocaïne que bien celle cette
poudre a été rajoutée numériquement
est-ce que vous apercevez le reflet
qu'on va percevoir ici hop c'est très
fugace on voit que le reflet que vous
allez voir qui se reflète sur le bureau
voilà blanc ne passe pas passe en
dessous de la carte la carte bancaire et
donc de la cocaïne signe que eh bien
cette carte bancaire assez cocaïne et
donc pas présente dans la vidéo
originale et qu'elle a été rajoutée
numériquement c'est un petit peu habile
mais bon il fallait leur père et où vous
avez vous rendez compte donc en
conclusion c'est donc un montage ma
chère audrey zelensky et la cocaïne
c'est un thème récurrent d un fox autour
du président ukrainien oui absolument un
autre exemple c'est cette interview
relayée largement par un conte un groupe
télégramme qui s'appelle un vaccine à
brengues s'inquiétant une chaîne
française publions donc régulièrement
des fausses informations autour du coc
vie de la vidéo la voici sur cette vidéo
on voit les sous titres de la soi-disant
interview qui dit à 7 heures du matin je
me suis levé j'ai fait une promenade
avec mon chien et je sniffe de la drogue
la vidéo originale elle est bien
différente la voix si on l'a retrouvé
ici elle émane d'un médias ukrainiens
qui s'appelle ukrainskaïa pravda elle
date de janvier 2019 vous l'apercevez
ici c'est une aile dure un peu plus
d'une heure c'est donc une longue
interview une interview qui date de
l'époque où souvenez-vous le président
était candidat à l'élection
présidentielle ukrainienne
il était à l'époque acteur à succès
l'extrait en question démarre à peu près
à 7 minutes 40 g vous les épargner et
dure plusieurs minutes qu'est-ce qu'il
dit le journaliste donc évoque les
rumeurs persistantes à l'époque on va y
revenir qui accusait volodymyr zelensky
donc de consommer de la cocaïne voici la
réponse de zelensky formidable
formidable non je suis assis sur quelque
chose de blanc il s'agit d'une syed une
chaise ce n'est pas de la coke je ne
consomme pas de drogues dont vous le
voyez c'est une traduction des tournées
avec encore un but la décrédibiliser le
président hu le président zelensky à
noter également que ce montage est
devenu tellement virale que la chaîne
qui a réalisé l'interview a dû se
justifier et dénoncer ce montage et le
tard l'article que vous apercevez ici
qui voit là pour affirmer donc c'était
un montage et cette rumeur de volodymyr
zelensky drogué à la cocaïne a pris des
proportions étonnantes oui absolument
lors de la campagne présidentielle de
2010 9 justement ce à quoi ce à quoi je
faisais référence qui opposait donc
volodymyr zelensky candidats à l'époque
au président sortant petro porochenko
ces rumeurs de drogue avait tellement
enflé que les candidats à l'époque nos
confrères de france info le rappelle
vous l'apercevez ici avait dû se plier à
des tests anti drogue c'est ce qu'on
aperçoit ici que le président petro
porochenko prochaine qu'on lui avait
choisi un laboratoire public vous allez
comprendre c'est en importance zelensky
un laboratoire privé de quoi susciter
naturellement les suspicions des
soutiens du président sortant comprenez
l'un le test de drogue de zeden ce qui
est
ea dont ces derniers avaient d'ailleurs
détourner un des clips de campagne de
volodymyr zelensky que voici ici je vous
montre le montage on y voit le candidat
à l'époque entouré d'ukrainiens se faire
renverser par un bus comprennent et il
n'a pas les idées claires et le message
est explicite le slogan de la campagne
dit chacun sa route c'est la traduction
que d'ukrainiens qui s'efface avec un
rail de cocaïne signifie à l'aide d'un
billet vous l'avez père vous l'avez
aperçu à noter qu en ukrainien route et
rail peuvent se traduire la même manière
doris cas à l'époque entre l'entourage
de porochenko avait démenti être à
l'origine du détournement en conclusion
donc vous l'avez compris vous avez une
ce qui est la cocaïne sud un fox
ancienne mais particulièrement tenace
qui refait surface régulièrement pour
décrédibiliser le président ukrainien
avec une nouveauté tout de même à noter
c'est que désormais c'est un fox émane
de comptes pro russes notamment à la
faveur de la guerre en ukraine des infos
qui s'était donc évidemment qu'ils
franchissent vous l'avez compris la
ligne blanche jolie belle chute merci
beaucoup antoine fenaux merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette demi heure
d'information on se retrouve dans
quelques instants pour un nouveau
journal dans ce paris direct
[Musique]